كنت أعلم متى أردت أن يموت
الفريق عندما وجدت حلاً كنت
تشاهده من أجلك صفحة المراهقين
لحساب Tick Tock لن يشفي الحب لي ،
أنشأت CNN ملف تعريف Tick Tock هذا
بمساعدة طفل يبلغ من العمر 14 عامًا وأولياء
أمورهم  قبل أن نتحكم فيه على مدار
ستة أيام ، نستخدم هذا الحساب لمعرفة
أنواع المحتوى الذي قد يخدمه التطبيق لشاب
يبدو وكأنه
يمنحك دليلًا حول كيفية تطوير
اضطراب الأكل وكيفية تقييد
تناولك لما فاجأني  معظم
المحتوى الذي تم تقديمه لي عندما كنت في
الوضع المقيد ولكن هذا يأتي لاحقًا
أولاً ، حسنًا ، لنفعل ذلك هذه هي
المرة الأولى التي سأفتح فيها علامة
Tick Tock وأبحث في
صفحة من أجلك في أول يومين قمت
بالتمرير  حسابات الاختبار الخاصة بك
لمدة 30 دقيقة تقريبًا ثلث
الوقت الذي يقضيه المراهق العادي
على التطبيق كل يوم وفقًا
لتقرير TechCrunch وشاهدت كل مقطع
فيديو صادفته في Fall مرة واحدة فقط في
البداية رأينا الكثير  من بين كل هذه
الأشياء الرائعة التي يمكن أن يفعلها البني ،
يمكنه أن يذهب مثل بقرة يمكنه أن يذهب موهبة
وهذا [
الموسيقى]
ولكن بعد حوالي 17 دقيقة من يومنا الأول ،
تلقينا هذا الفيديو الآن وصلنا
إلى فيديو مباشر  كل ما نراه حقًا
هو الجزء السفلي من هذه الفتاة في الإطار ،
يبدو أن هذا هو الهدف من هذا
الفيديو وبعد حوالي 18 دقيقة من اليوم الثاني ،
صادفنا هذا الفيديو ، والآن لدينا
مقطع يحتوي على علامة تصنيف الصحة العقلية
يجب أن يقتلك إذا كنت تريد
قتلي ، فلدينا نوع من
الإشارة المحجبة للانتحار هنا نوع من
الموضوعات الناضجة يحدث هنا أعتقد أن
الكثير من الآباء يجلسون هناك
لمدة ثانية أعتقد أن تيك توك كان يدور
حول مجنون الرقص.  في اليوم الثالث ،
بدأنا البحث عن المحتوى باستخدام
مصطلحات البحث من كل من الدعوى المرفوعة
من قبل مكتب المدعي العام في إنديانا
والبحث من مجموعة الدفاع عن السلامة عبر الإنترنت ،
مركز لمواجهة
الكراهية الرقمية ، تزعم شركة Indiana AG أن
المراهقين يمكنهم كتابة مصطلحات بحث جزئية وإكمال
Apple تلقائيًا باستخدام
الاقتراحات التي قد تعرض
محتوى غير لائق قالت Tick Tock
إنها لا تعلق على التقاضي المعلق
ولكن سلامة المستخدم هي أولوية قصوى
أولاً ، قمنا بتكرار بحثهم عن
محتوى متعلق بالكحول والمخدرات
ولم نعثر على الفور على أي شيء
يبدو أنه ضار.  لا نقول أي شيء
له علاقة بالكحول في
الصفحة الأولى من نتائج البحث ، ثم قمنا
بتكرار عمليات البحث عن
المحتوى الجنسي ، فنكتب Ki والنتيجة الثانية
هي kin Tick Tock ، فنحن نحصل على
نوع جميل من محتوى البالغين
نرى هنا
[موسيقى]
نحصل على كل هذه
الاقتراحات الأخرى من عائلة تيك توك دادي ، يمكن لسرير حبل توك توك أن يكون
سيناريو توك توك تقريبيًا وربما تكتب
كي لأنك تبحث عن شيء
لا علاقة له بهذا تمامًا ولكنه كان
نتيجة البحث الثانية ، وهكذا يمكنك أن
ترى كيف يمكن لشخص ما أن يصادف
هذا النوع من المحتوى عن
طريق الخطأ عندما بحثنا عن المصطلحات
المذكورة في البحث من قبل مركز
مكافحة الكراهية الرقمية ، وجدنا
العشرات من مقاطع الفيديو المتعلقة
باضطرابات الأكل وإيذاء الذات Tick Tock
رفض بحث المجموعة
قائلاً إنه لم يكن يمثل
تجربة شخص حقيقي على المنصة ، ولا
يزال العديد من علامات التصنيف المذكورة في البحث نشطة وسرعان ما
قادتنا إلى الاهتمام بالمحتوى فورًا ،
تبدو النتيجة الأولى وكأنها
تتعلق بالتعافي من اضطرابات الأكل  في هذا الفيديو ،
لدينا شخص يتحدث عن رسم
الطعام حتى لا يضطروا في الواقع إلى تناول
الطعام ، يتحدث هذا الشخص عن تناول
الأطعمة الآمنة المضطربة. الكثير من
مقاطع الفيديو هذه لديك آلاف المشاهدات ،
مئات التعليقات ، الآلاف من المحفوظات
والكثير من مقاطع الفيديو هذه  يبدو أنهم
مستهدفون نوعًا ما للتحدث
عن التعافي ،
لكن ليس من الواضح دائمًا
أنه من المهم حقًا أن
يقول الناس حقيقتهم وأن يكون لديهم
أصواتهم للتحدث عن تعافيهم ولكن
السؤال هو أنه يجب على تيك توك أن
يرسل ذلك مرة أخرى عن قصد و  مرة أخرى إلى
فتيات يبلغن من العمر 13 عامًا ربما لم يكن
لديهن بعد المفردات أو
الذكاء العاطفي حتى يتمكنوا من التعامل مع
هذه الأنواع من المفاهيم ، قد تبدو هذه المقاطع
صادمة ولكن في بعض الحالات اخترنا
عدم إظهار المحتوى الأكثر إزعاجًا
وصراحة عندما  لقد نقرنا
على حساب هذا الشخص الذي تراه في
الوصف ، حيث يقول إن بعض مقاطع الفيديو الخاصة بي بها
ندوب مؤذية ، لذا
أطلق تحذيرًا في اليوم الخامس قمنا بتشغيل
الوضع المقيد ، وهي ميزة يقول Tick Tock إنها
تحد من مقاطع الفيديو التي قد تكون
غير مناسبة لبعض الأشخاص ،
أعدنا إنشاء نفس عمليات البحث التي أجريناها في
اليوم الثالث لمعرفة ما إذا كانت ستغير
نتائجنا ، فهذا شبه إباحي
وجدنا أن الوضع المقيد لا يبدو أنه
يقيد الكثير من أي شيء رأيناه بالفعل
نفس الفيديو عندما لم نكن في
وضع غير مقيد I  أعتقد أننا ربما
رأينا هذا أيضًا وهذا
يبدو في الواقع مثل جميع
مقاطع الفيديو نفسها التي رأيناها سابقًا يا
إلهي ، أصبح
قمع الناس
سيئًا للغاية لدرجة أنهم لا يستطيعون تنظيف
أسنانهم.  لم تظهر
قبل أن تكون أكثر من وزنك إذا كان
لديك أو لدى أي شخص تعرفه أسئلة
حول صورة الجسم أو التمرينات الرياضية ، فمن
المهم أن تعرف أن المساعدة موجودة ،
لذلك من المثير للاهتمام أن Tick
Tock يبدو أنه أدرك أنني كنت
بالنظر إلى الكثير من
المحتوى المتعلق باضطراب الأكل أو فقدان الوزن ، ومع ذلك ،
أثناء وجودنا في الوضع المقيد ، لم
يتغير نوع الحقائق التي يمكنني رؤية
كل هذه الأشياء التي يقول توك توك إنه
يوجه المستخدمين في بعض الأحيان إلى موارد تتعلق
بمشكلات مثل تناول الطعام  الاضطرابات وإيذاء
الذات استنادًا إلى مصطلحات البحث التي
يستخدمونها ردًا على أسئلة من CNN ، قامت
الشركة بتحديث
علامتي تصنيف إضافيتين لاضطرابات الأكل ، لذا فهي الآن
تعيد توجيهها إلى موارد الدعم ، حسنًا ،
نحن نسرع ​​في اليومين الخامس والسادس.
لمدة 30 دقيقة
أثناء التواجد في الوضع المقيد ورأينا
ارتفاعًا طفيفًا في مقاطع الفيديو المتعلقة بالصحة العقلية ،
لدينا مقطع
فيديو آخر متعلق بالاكتئاب مرة أخرى في التعليقات التي
لديكم يمكنني الارتباط بهذا الأمر وأنا فقط
في المدرسة الإعدادية يمكنني الارتباط بهذا
وأنا  أنا في المدرسة الثانوية ، حسنًا ، لقد حصلنا على
علامة انتحار ، فأنا لا أقتل نفسك في
شرح اكتئابي لوالدتي ، وفي
محادثة ، أبلغت CNN عن أكثر من
عشرة مقاطع فيديو صادفناها أثناء
تجربتنا للتأكيد على إزالة ثلاثة
منها لانتهاكها
إرشادات المجتمع بما في ذلك هذا الذي
رأيته في الجزء العلوي من هذا الفيديو ، لقد سمعت
دقات قلبي في أذني مثل
طبلة التحذير ، ثم فيث ، كنت
أقنع نفسي تقريبًا أنني فعلت ذلك ، لقد عرفنا
منذ فترة طويلة أن هذا المحتوى في الواقع
حول إيذاء النفس والانتحار يمكن أن يكون لهما
تأثير تحريضي على الشباب
وتطبيع إيذاء النفس أمر
خطير للغاية
لم يتصرف حسابنا التجريبي تمامًا مثل المراهق الحقيقي
كما أن الكثير من المحتوى الذي رأيناه
سقط أيضًا في منطقة رمادية  قد
يكون هذا مصدر قلق للوالدين أو لا ، لكنه
أظهر ما يمكن أن يواجهه المراهق على
التطبيق في بيان قال المتحدث باسمه بن
رايث إن Tick Tock ملتزمة ببناء
تجارب مناسبة للعمر
للمراهقين ويقدم الاقتران العائلي ،
كما أزالت Tick Tock عمليتي بحث  الاقتراحات
التي أدت إلى المحتوى الجنسي أضافت Tick Tock
أيضًا العديد من ميزات سلامة الشباب
بما في ذلك مرشحات الكلمات المحددة لوقت الشاشة
وخيارات لتنويع خلاصات
المستخدمين ، لا يزال خبراء السلامة عبر الإنترنت
يحثون Tick Tock على فعل المزيد وفي
الوقت نفسه يقولون إن الآباء يجب أن يكونوا
على دراية بذلك  ما يراه أطفالهم على التطبيق
يحتاجون إليه لإجراء محادثات
مع أطفالهم يسألونهم عما
تراه ثم نساعدهم في وضع
سياق لذلك من خلال إجراء تلك
المحادثة يمكننا في الواقع مساعدة الأطفال
والآباء على فهم أفضل
لعصر الوسائط الاجتماعية الجديد هذا الذي نحن فيه  أفضل أو
أسوأ تعيش في